>> ♪ ♪
>> SO MUCH FOR CIVILITY IN
AMERICA.
FIRST LADY MELANIA MELT WITH
BOOS SPEAKING ABOUT THE OPIOID
CRISIS DURING A YOUTH SUMMIT IN
BALTIMORE.
>> [BOOING].
>> THE FIRST LADY RESPONDED WITH
A STATEMENT:
WE LIVE IN A DEMOCRACY AND
EVERYONE IS ENTITLED TO THEIR
OPINION BUT APPROXIMATE -- BUT
WE HAVE A SERIOUS CRISIS IN OUR
COUNTRY.
AT THE TIME, SHE WAS SO
GRACEFUL.
YOU ARE FIGHTING WITH ME BUT I
AM FIGHTING FOR YOU.
HOW DO YOU THINK THAT SOMEONE
WHO HAS HAD DISAGREEMENTS WITH
THIS ADMINISTRATION, HOW DO YOU
FEEL ABOUT HER STATEMENT YOU MAY
BE FIGHTING WITH ME BUT I AM
STILL FIGHTING FOR YOU IN A
LARGER ISSUE AT STAKE HERE?
>> I THINK IT WAS GRACEFUL.
SHE SHOULD HAVE SAID IT.
I DON'T THINK SHE WAS GOING TO
FIRE BACK.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT MOSTLY
KIDS.
THE SECOND THING TO SAY IS WOW,
SHE HAD TO KNOW SHE WAS GOING
INTO THE LION'S DEN.
HER HUSBAND HAD DEMOLISHED
BALTIMORE AND SAID THE MOST
HORRIBLE THINGS:
NOBODY WANTS TO LIVE HERE.
RAT INVESTED.
BALTIMORE HAS DEFICITS, BUT ONCE
YOU GO INTO SOMEBODY'S HOUSE
AFTER TELLING THEM THEY ARE
UNWORTHY, I --
>> TRUMP DIDN'T DEMOLISH
BALTIMORE.
BALTIMORE DEMOLISHED THEMSELVES.
>> BUT EVEN IF SOMEONE IS SICK
OR HAS PROBLEMS IT DOESN'T HELP
THEM.
THE KIDS MAY HAVE HEARD IT FROM
THEIR PARENTS.
THE WAY A CHILD REACT IS TO SAY
YOU ARE A BAD GUY.
I THOUGHT SHE HANDLED IT WITH
SOME GRACE.
I THINK SHE HAD TO KNOW WHAT WAS
GOING ON WHEN SHE STEPPED INTO
BALTIMORE.
>> LAWRENCE YOU SPEND TIME ON
CAMPUSES.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
IS IT A SMALLER FRACTIONS OF THE
POPULATION?
>> I THINK THERE IS A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE OUT RIGHT
CULTURE AND GENERAL RESPECT.
I APPLAUD THE FIRST LADY FOR NOT
WANTING TO MAKE IT ABOUT HER.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO SWING BACK.
MORE PEOPLE WOULD SUPPORT HIM AS
A RESULT OF THIS.
TO FOLLOW-UP ON JUAN'S POINT
ABOUT BALTIMORE.
I THINK THAT'S WRONG.
I HAVE BEEN TO BALTIMORE.
I TALKED TO THE RESIDENTS OF
BALTIMORE.
THEY ARE MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE CORRUPTION IN BALTIMORE.
YOU HAVE THE FIRST LADY GOING IN
THERE TO HIGHLIGHT ISSUES.
IN A GRACEFUL WAY.
THE KIDS SHOULD HAVE BEEN TAUGHT
RESPECT.
THERE ARE MANY POLICIES I
DISAGREED WITH.
I NEVER BOOED THEM BECAUSE I
WANT TO HEAR THEIR PERSPECTIVE.
>> DANA, DO YOU THINK IF TRUMP
WINS THE NEXT ELECTION THERE
WILL BE A SEPARATION BETWEEN HIM
AND MELANIA?
WILL THERE BE PARTS OF AMERICA
THAT SUPPORTER RATHER THAN
ASCRIBE IS  -- ASCRIBING THE
NEGATIVE THINGS HE DOES TO HER?
>> SHE HAS GROWN INCREDIBLE
GRACE.
ENGLISH IS NOT HER FIRST
LANGUAGE.
GETTING UP TO SPEAK ALL THE TIME
IF YOU ARE GOING TO A PLACE YOU
MIGHT BE BOO'D.
ONE OF THE THINGS HAPPENING THIS
QUARTER IS PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
DONATING HIS SALARY TO THE
OPENED CRISIS.
-- OPIOID CRISIS.
I HATE TO SEE ANYBODY BOO'D.
I WOULD NOT PARTICIPATE IN THAT.
AS TO THE FUTURE, I DO THINK
THAT GOING FORWARD, BECAUSE SHE
MADE A MARK ON BE THE BEST
CAMPAIGN FOCUSSING ON CHILDREN
AND OPIOIDS, FOR A SECOND TERM
THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR HER
TO TAKE ON SOMETHING MORE.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE FIRST LADY
ADDRESS THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
AND ADOPTION.
NOVEMBER IS NATIONAL ADOPTION
MONTH.
HER JOY THAT SHE HAS TALKING
ABOUT CHILDREN AND AROUND
CHILDREN IS PERSUASIVE.
I DON'T THINK THE TWO OF THEM
WON'T BE SEPARATED.
>> RIGHT IN THE NATION'S EYES.
GREG, YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> IN THE ERA OF TRUMP ANY
LINKAGE TO HIM FROM MARRIAGE TO
BLOOD TO WEARING A HAT, IT
INCRIMINATES YOU.
IT'S WHEREVER YOU GO.
IF THIS HAPPENED TO MITCHELL THE
MEDIA WOULD TORCH THE SCHOOL.
THE RULE IN MY LIFE IS NEVER
TALK TO A LARGE GROUP OF KIDS.
THEY WOULD BOO THEIR OWN PARENTS
AND HECKLE THE POPE.
GIVE HER CREDIT.
IMAGINE IF YOU MOVED TO AN
EASTERN EUROPEAN COUNTRY BECAUSE
YOUR SPOUSE BECAME PRESIDENT AND
YOU HAVE TO GO SPEAK TO A GROUP
OF BRATS AND YOUR ENGLISH ACCENT
IS HILARIOUS.
SHE SUPPORT JUST GRACEFUL.
SHE IS BRAVE.
>> AND PEOPLE ARE ADVOCATING TO
LOWER THE VOTING AGE.
>> THEY MIGHT BE IMPULLSIVE.
BE AT A REALLY AT FLORIDA AND
USE BS IN FRONT OF CHILDREN.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> KIDS ARE GOING TO BE KIDS.
>> I AM SURE THEY ALL WENT HOME
AND GOT A GOOD TALKING TO FROM